Voiceover:We have this
girl right over here
and she is 1.7 meters tall
and she's standing in the sun.
The sun's at an angle with
respect to the ground.
Given where the sun is right now,
her shadow is 3.1 meters long.
What I want you to do is pause this video
and try to figure that angle of the sun
relative to the ground
or another way, let me be
a little bit more specific.
Pause the video and try to
figure out what this angle is
and figure it out in terms of radiance.
As you might imagine this,
we have an angle
and then we have the length of two sides
and we could figure out the
ratios of the lengths of sides.
This might be involving a
little bit of trigonometry.
Which of our trig functions
if we're talking about
this angle right over here.
Which of our trig functions
deal with the opposite
and the adjacent?
Or we could remind of ourselves
with a little bit of sohcahtoa.
Sine is opposite over hypotenuse.
Cosine is adjacent over hypotenuse.
Tangent is opposite over adjacent.
Tangent is what we would use,
it's dealing with opposite and adjacent.
We could say that the tangent of theta
is equal to 1.7 meters over 3.1 meters.
We have to figure out some
angle theta in radiance
where if I take the tangent of it,
I'm going to get 1.7 over 3.1.
Or another way we could think about it,
we could take the inverse tan
function, or tangent function
of both sides of this sometimes
called the arctangent.
If we take the inverse
tangent of both sides of this
we are going to be left with theta
is equal to the inverse
tangent of 1.7 over 3.1.
This isn't something that's very easy
to kind of look at the unit circle
and try to figure out
what this is going to be.
Let's just use our
calculator for this one.
Let's see we want to
take the inverse tangent.
Give me the angle whose tangent
is the number that I'm ...
The argument that I'm going to give
to this inverse tangent function.
The inverse tangent of 1.7 over 3.1
and before I even press enter here.
Let me make sure I'm in the right mode.
No, I'm not in the right mode.
I was in degree mode,
let me go into radian mode.
We said that we wanted
the answer in radiance
so let's exit from this.
Now we are going to get
our answer in radiance.
If we would round to the nearest hundreds
this would give us about
pretty close to 0.50.
This is approximately equal to 0.50
if we round to the nearest hundreds.
That's the measure of
this angle in radiance.
I could write 0.50 radiance.